ويعد تجميد الاصول عقوبه تفرض على اشخاص
وكيانات ويمكن فرضها عبر منظومات
الاقليميه كالاتحاد الاوروبي او دول
منفرده في هذا السياق اكد القذال
الاوروبيونه في ختام القمه الاوكرانيه
الاوروبيه عزمهم على تكثيف الجهود
لاستخدام الاصول الروسيه المجمده لدعم
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا وبشان الاصول
الروسيه المجمده اعلنت وزاره العدل
والخزانه الامريكيتين في يونيو الماضي انا
واشنطن وحلفاء الاوروبيين جمدوا 330 مليار
دولار من اصول النخبه الروسيه والبنك
المركزي الروسي وكان وزير العمل الروسي
قدر قبل شهور مبالغ بلاده التي جمدتها
الدول الغربيه بحوالي 300 مليار دولار
ومن جهتها افلت وحلت العمل الاتابعه
للحلفاء الغربيين بتجميد 30 مليار دولار
من الاصول المملوكه للروس في ديسمبر
الماضي اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي تجميده نحو
19 مليار يورو من اصول اثرياء وكيانات
الروسيه اجمالا يخضع الف ومئت 241 فردا
روسيا
و18 كيانا لعقوبات فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي
منذ بدء الحرب
وبدورها جمدت بريطانيا اصولا روسيه تزيد
قيمتها عن عشرين مليارا و500 مليون دولار
يملكها الروس وفي سياق نفسه اعلنت استونيا
الاثاره الماضيه عزمها على وضع اطار
قانوني لمصادره 17 مليار دولار قيمه قيمه
اصول روسيا ونقلت وكاله بلومبر بان
الحكومه الالمانيه مستعده لتلبيه مطلب
اوكرانيا باستخدام الاصول الروسيه المجمده
لديها والتي تصل الى خمسه مليارات ونصف
المليار دولار اذا فعل حلفاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي الشيء نفسه ومن جانبها هذلت
روسيا مرارا باتخاذ خطوات مشابهه وردت
بالفعل امس الجمعه باعلانها تامينها 500
من الاصول والممتلكات العائده لاثرياء
اوكرانيين في شبه جزيره القرمن